like an Aztec grandfather comments I do
through the internet that he just
learned to use he got done with the
sundial music anyone can do it
hi guys it's Tuesday you're on it's
great and it's time to talk back to you
let's start on that was me falling
softly and gently and elegantly down a
well
LM love life new person to person to
person probably they don't know what a
new person comments on one of my social
medias I praise the crap on of them and
welcome to the Enbridge of Justice which
works
I welcome them to the it's grace family
that's how music sounds in my brain Ln
love life more like LG love life sponsor
not really at all whatsoever put your
back into it
this episode of its grace is inspired by
music you brew where can I get a camp
Takota shirt because I want one like a
lot are you for real can't the core not
call me dumb doubt never meant to make
you cry but seriously I've been saying
captain Cottam so much sky york new
person you person-to-person sky you are
more like sky fork the lesser-known
superhero second cousin to Skype so
everyone loves you a boy will there ever
be a way for me to watch Camp Takota
even if I don't have money to buy it you
know I'm not sure I know you'll have to
use money to pay to watch camp Takota
but cam Dakota I know one if God was one
of us he mic him to code
on the bus jazz Chando a new person new
person in person jazzy jazz C chin no
one more like Jackie Chan what the hell
is great boom boom thank you really hard
about getting the camp to go to film
plastic I don't know how to take on the
fence there just push your fence go by
it now
then you do some new person in person in
person the YouTube stuff might the
YouTube muff has a very special site
they'll never go there I don't even know
if I think this maybe I'm just gonna
write a movie we shot this video so long
ago a memory says that quote and now
look at camp Takota calm
it'll spice up your lives it's simply
say I'm twenty three new person to
person to person is simply say I'm
twenty three more like it's simply Sam
calling 23 times a day cuz she's not
that simple she's extra super high
maintenance and really not self-aware
when labeling herself in her usernames
you can't Dakota let me so and I don't
know how the rest goes wait do we get to
figure out how the rest goes on Friday
she's a brick and I'm drowning slowly
and kiss it did you didn't know we're so
sounds good 9th - to person to person to
person sounds good 9 - more like sounds
good
make mine too - double make mine a
double
that is just take it
and put it into mine and then give him
water no I scuba Brewers all I think
about is drinking martinis and sitting
with my dog and going on tumblr checking
tumblr texts grace Helbig this yeah I
set this quote on Kippur pairs podcast
which came out yesterday which link down
there go listen to it's a really fun
time celebrate now let's go to you to
Chiquita banana add a little new person
to person to person I'm a little more
like Chicken Little and guess what the
skies falling down is that a song I
don't know I just said it like it wasn't
a song that's what singing is saying
words like that's a song your grace are
you okay I'm friends with the monster
that's under my bed get along with the
voices his son I'm great
somebody the brown your person to person
to person Samantha brown more like brown
is the color up turns people put makeup
tutorial and even put a superlative
in front of it so I don't know if you if
it's the best or the worst with the both
medium something but I like that it
leaves me wanting more it may give me
more give me more give me give me more I
need to be validated
Dustin James Hughes new person to person
to person Justin James here's more like
Justin James excuse a little young bro
oh do you want your videos to I thought
I was the only one that's at that house
on
[Music]
well let's never talk you back to you
guys today I hope you enjoyed this
pattern a couple quick announcements one
I don't know if I mentioned this is a
brand new episode of Graces faces on the
I love makeup channel with Gen X penn
and andrea russett we did the face flop
challenge it's a new challenge that we
started right here on YouTube where you
try and mimic your roommate or friends
signature makeup style go check it out
was really fun funny and kept Twitter
calm